what's up guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Katie Dubois today we're checking out a
video that I want to see really bad
because I love this guy
Arnold pranks fans as the Terminator for
charity let's do this wow these are
really lightly that's cool I wish I was
there man
come with me if you want to live I'm
looking for sunglasses
it is protect from shotgun glass I think
this is you I'm the Terminator who are
you I'm the Terminator am the t800
cybernetic organism he would issue a
little endoskeleton
this time complex artistic get out just
joking
who's this Arnold Schwarzenegger this is
my mind I'll be back I'll be back I
ah that was fun it was just me
so imagine what happens do this together
so what are you waiting for Google is
calm and ended now we will hit the PDF
Terminator Genisys we will say 1 - like
hasta la vista baby
we will tell people they'll be back or
the benefit after-school programs click
this button here do it
I insist
he's got a great sense of humor that was
fun that was so cool that's like one of
the coolest things a celebrity could do
for their fans oh man face off on
Hollywood Boulevard with him in hell
yeah so great oh both just kept it going
like completely convicted I have no idea
how I would respond there what a
brilliant prank to to to you that was so
[ __ ] awesome I really
we're like 10 to 20 minutes away from
there and we totally missed out I would
have grabbed Donald's crotch when I
thought he was a wax
he might have punched you though how
cool would it be my kill by my life or
to maker put you on the floor and then
you would ask [ __ ] me
shows dominance this is for charity put
my penis in your ass I can't do it
anyway guys thanks for saying that was
out that was a pure delight I [ __ ]
love that as a fan of the Terminator
franchise especially part two I always
consider that like either my first or
second favorite movie depending on how I
feel so yeah that was [ __ ] awesome
still laughing when he's like get out
and the guys like okay I'm so good so
good that was great oh my god I would
totally be fanboying out of that happen
to me if you guys are new to the channel
you can subscribe to the real rejects
you can check out Katie Dubois channel
the Katie Dubois channel and you can
follow us on Facebook Instagram Twitter
and vine because we can get money with
product placements with enough followers
so I can be like oh here's a picture of
Katie in a bikini ah
product placement she's holding fit T
fit T if you're there I want I want your
Qi
supposedly a great weight loss results
yeah sounds good yeah you just poop out
a lot of things and you get thin and I
like pooping I like pooping Katie my BAE
cougar okay sometimes you just get the
best script ideas when you're pooping
you know whatever works City